from fighting a 90s comedy icon to
gaining the powers of a duck DC's main
man Lobo knows how to have a frag in
good time
before investigating lobo's illustrious
comic book career and the characters
conflicted Origins it's essential to
look at his value and impact although
Marvel and DC Comics have long stood as
the pillars of superhero comics they are
two different sides of the same coin
DC's lineup of mascots is commonly
displayed as god-like humans capable of
Feats Beyond mortal comprehension
meanwhile the roster filling Marvel's
Bullpen are traditionally more
monster-like hidden behind masks and
mutations that make them seem inhuman
while DC's Boy Scouts were icons of the
genre for decades by the 1990s audiences
had begun to lean towards the Grimmer
comics from Marvel while Spider-Man and
Batman duked it out as the top sellers
of 1990 Marvel was winning fan affection
thanks to grittier and more hardened
characters like Punisher and the newly
arrived cable Above All Else X-Men's
Wolverine was slicing his way to the top
of the comic book food chain with his
cynical snarl and Rogue Spirit to combat
the changing tides these C opted to
revive a certain near forgotten but an
alluringly tepid villain from Omega men
number three names Lobo
please stop making me blush Lobo
received a self-titled mini-series by
the end of 1990 originally serving as
parody of Marvel's darker characters
Lobo quickly found a sincere fan base as
its titular anti-hero developed into one
of DC's most popular personalities
speaking to newsarama Lobo co-creator
Keith Giffin said I have no idea why
lopo took off I came up with him as an
indictment of the Punisher Wolverine
somehow he caught on as the high
violence poster boy go figure unlike
most Ultra popular comic characters that
have been around for decades Lobo could
be considered a newcomer to the genre
still that has not stopped DC Comics
from making his Origins and backstory as
complicated as possible when the main
man first appeared in Omega Man number
three he was the visual opposite of the
scruffy looking King leather-clad biker
portrayed today instead he wore a shiny
orange and purple skin type bodysuit
with David Bowie inspired makeup
introduced as a bounty hunter this
original Lobo was the last survivor of
his extraterrestrial species the
velorpians who were wiped out by another
alien race because of their inherently
violent behavior however in Lobo Volume
2 number zero it was revealed that he
was responsible for the demise of his
people the zarnians after releasing a
plague of flying scorpion-like insects
in 2011 as part of DC's company-wide New
52 retcon the recognizably bulky Lobo
was revealed to be an imposter and was
replaced by a skinnier zarnian with
similar abilities short-lived this
updated version of Lobo defeated his
former self and starred in his own
self-titled series thankfully after yet
another relaunch of its characters with
DC rebirth DC returned Lobo to his
grubbier identity as is evident lobo's
Origins are as complicated as they come
and and that's without getting into the
character's history with cloning
regardless of his many variations and
inconsistent Origins Lobo is almost
always portrayed as a ruthless and
Powerful Intergalactic Bounty Hunter
he's a formidable foe to DC's heaviest
hitters and nearly impossible to kill
truthfully the last zarnian is best
described as overpowered off the top
Lobo Has the strength speed and
durability to match DC's greatest heroes
including Superman although the potency
of his abilities can be inconsistent the
space biker has even more tricks up his
sleeves not that he often wears anything
with sleeves like his Marvel inspiration
Wolverine Lobo has a keen sense of smell
and can regenerate his body however the
DC character's power goes beyond fixing
wounds efficiently as he can regenerate
an entirely new body from a single drop
of blood essentially cloning himself and
while he couldn't tell by looking at him
the gruff Bounty Hunter has a genius
level intellect this is mostly when it
comes to matters of violence and destroy
action but he does have a working
knowledge of numerous cultures around
the Galaxy and he can speak in over 17
000 unique languages adding to the
special skills section on lobo's resume
are an inherent ability to sense
weakness in his opponents and expertise
in multiple forms of combat however what
makes the character so over the top
compared to his comic book peers is the
fact that he was banished from the
afterlife during the Lobos back
miniseries essentially granting him
immortality
when you're indestructible the last of
your kind and have your own space
traveling motorbike you don't need to
play by everyone else's rules still Lobo
maintains a strict code of ethics as
perverse as they may be like his name
suggests the main man is a lone wolf
selfish and arrogant on his solo Journey
Through Time however as a bounty hunter
Lobo is a man of his word once he signs
a contract there is no going back while
there are many examples of Lobo
satisfying his obligations in comic
books the best instance occurred in
Superman the animated series the biker
appears in two consecutive episodes of
the cartoon where he first completes his
obligation of capturing the Man of Steel
and then upon being captured himself
joins forces with Superman and pledges a
new oath to leave Earth alone
subsequently while Lobo proudly fulfills
his Oaths he's made a habit of never
going above and beyond as if giving any
more than promised would equally break
his word it may be the main man's
trustworthy codes and surprising honest
D that made Stan Lee choose him as his
favorite DC character as he once
revealed in a YouTube Interview well I
don't know if you can call him a hero
for many years Lobo was accompanied by a
bulldog named dog spelled with a W the
grizzled Bounty Hunter took offense to
anybody who referred to the canine as
his pet the animal first appeared in the
1992 One-Shot Lobo paramilitary
Christmas special and would remain a
loyal companion to the space biker
despite the latter showing zero
emotional attachment to the creature
although dog visually appears to be a
standard Earth canine he has alien
Origins as made evident by his ability
to survive in the vacuum of space while
he travels along with Lobo through the
cosmos additionally the animal has been
known to smoke Lobo cigars at times
lobo's Detachment from the mutt serves
the Bounty Hunter as he often uses him
as a meat Shield still the main man has
been known to go out of his way to save
dog from danger unfortunately it's Lobo
who is responsible for the animal's
death by aggressively stomping on him
while thinking he's possessed by an
alien virus in Lobo Volume 2 issue
number 58. there's some uncertainty
about whether the animals survived the
traumatic event as dog later reappears
in Green Lantern Vol 4 Issue Number 54
but in this iteration Global
acknowledges him as a pet and his
appearance has changed additionally dog
was canonically revived after DC's
Flashpoint event taking part in a
mission with Lobo and Harley Quinn and
Harley's little black book number six
although the main man has mostly shown
indifference towards the dog that
follows him around Lobo does have a
favorite animal the space dolphin
affectionately referring to him as
fishies the hardened space biker has a
soft spot for the floating Cosmic
aquatic mammals in the events of the one
shot Lobo slash demon Halloween logo is
required to think about one nice thing
in order to defeat a terrible monster
which proves a difficult task for the
angry biker so he thinks of the fishies
Crux a rare smile and saves the Galaxy
lobo's connection to space Dolphins was
first explored in Lobo Volume 2 issue
number 34 in which he spends an
afternoon with the animals to relax
after a hard night running into trouble
the main man becomes a champion of the
space creatures after saving them from
poachers he's even been known to ride
one after developing a bond with a
specific dolphin named Lundgren later
another space dolphin becomes lobo's
personal assistant when the bounty
hunter is serving as the Archbishop of a
new religion
swearing liquor women and violence top
Lobos list of all time favorite things
which made it all the more jarring when
the bounty hunter swore all of them off
during the events of DC's 52 a team of
Heroes discovered the main man operating
a refugee camp in a ravaged sector of
space as the appointed Archbishop of the
first Celestial Church of the triple
fish God the reborn Lobo is the
caretaker of the mystical Emerald eye of
ekron and leader to the displaced
Monsters of sector 3500 later in the
same series after helping the super team
of explorers Archbishop Lobo delivers
the sacraled emerald eye to his
triple-headed fish God in exchange for
the magical artifact the god agrees to
relinquish Lobos solemn vow of
non-violence as it turns out he should
have received the gift first upon
learning that the emerald is the only
thing that can kill the dolphin like God
logo makes the surprise move of
destroying his own deity
based on lobo's skewed code of ethics
you'd think he'd be one of the last
people to join Earth's shining pillars
of heroics yet for a Time the main man
put aside his murderous bounty hunting
Rampage and joined Batman's new lineup
of the Justice League of America of
course convincing the last sarnian to
join the good guys was no simple task
and it started with the Renegade Bounty
Hunter serving a sentence as a member of
The Suicide Squad in the events of
Justice League versus The Suicide Squad
Amanda Waller's original Suicide Squad
gets into a tussle with Superman's
supergroup a new team is formed that
includes Lobo alongside powerful
villains such as Dr Polaris and rustum
led by Maxwell Lord unfortunately the
latter has control of the Bounty Hunter
by way of brainwashing always the
detective Batman uses a bomb to explode
lobo's head forcing it to regenerate and
essentially clearing out Maxwell Lord's
influence afterwards in a debt of
gratitude Lobo accepts Batman's
invitation to his new team with just
League of America alongside Adam Killer
Frost and Black Canary however after
serving a term Lobo considers his debt
paid and returns to his space traveling
bounty hunting
and get a cucumber water or something
I'm super parched
Lobo is not associated with one
particular hero unlike so many other
villains and anti-heroes Deadpool is
organically linked to the X-Men Black
Adam shares history with Shazam and
Venom wouldn't exist without Spider-Man
but the main man is a force unto himself
traveling the DC Universe and starting
fights with anyone and everyone
including Superman Batman and Wonder
Woman similarly the character is
seemingly not limited to his original
publishing company's roster as he's also
had incidents with Wolverine Judge Dredd
and even Santa Claus still one of lobo's
most popular comic book run-ins occurred
in a 1997 two-part Series in which he
faced the mask the mask is best known
for the 1994 feature film of the same
name in which the character was
portrayed by Jim Carrey but not many
fans are aware that the mask started in
comic books the character debuted with a
Trilogy of limited series in the early
90s inspired by The Joker big head is a
dangerous character with powers that
were Works similarly to cartoon physics
including shape-shifting body
manipulation instantaneous healing and
immortality unsurprisingly when mask and
lobo's paths crossed it proved to be
catastrophic destroying Manhattan along
with an entire solar system subsequently
logo slash mask has become a cult
classic among comic readers for its
over-the-top nature and a
thought-provoking twist ending
one reason that comic books are so
popular and earn as many adaptations in
film as they do is that creators and
Publishers rarely Miss A Creative
opportunity the limitlessness of comic
books even led the two largest
competitive publishing companies to
Trump their rivalry long enough to
collaborate on an entirely new universe
amalgam Comics was a two-year collection
of books that Blended Marvel and DC
cross-breeding their most popular
characters into all new Heroes such as
Iron Lantern and Doctor Strange fate
again not to miss a golden opportunity
the comical Lobo was melded with one of
Marvel's more off-beat characters
powered the duck Lobo the duck was a
One-Shot title that was released in the
second series of amalgam Comics the
series follows the titular character and
the shape-shifting impossible dog as
they investigate murders of other
amalgam characters along the way the
main duck comes into conflict with a
range of wacky villains including called
kidney lady and Dr bong face
unfortunately the book ends on a
cliffhanger that was left unfulfilled
still the humor of the single issue has
shined as a highlight of the Publishing
Company crossover event despite
remaining outside of the main continuity
[Music]